it's important to collaborate so one of
the important things I finally running
the business is how important is to
collaborate with others and I think too
many entrepreneurs try to do within
themselves and you may have been burned
in the past by hiring somebody didn't
work out and you figure you know what
I'm just going to do it all myself and
not involve other people because I know
it's gonna get done right and nobody
else can do it like me or nobody else
will care as much as me and I get that
you may have been burned and that will
cause you to be more defensive and more
careful the next time but it's important
to understand that you can't do
everything yourself look if you have a
big vision if you want to have a
positive impact you want to build a
successful company you can't do it all
yourself one because you only have so
many hours of the day that you can
actually get work done until you're not
an expert on everything right you've got
to figure out what you are among the
best in the world at and focus on those
things and the other things eliminate
I'll automate and delegate the people
who love doing that going really good so
I'm here in Seattle we're in bellevue
right now i'm on a trip with microsoft
and this is jen everyone friend of the
channel you've seen her a couple times
on the channel and and jen lives in
portland and and i wanted to be on this
video too because she's super active and
involved in in the book and so we're
collaborating and so one of the things
that I found to be really stressful was
doing a lot of the research for the book
and doing a lot of the interviews and
writing out all the interviews so part
of the book they don't know what the
books about you so it's still so much on
the hush-hush but I'm not you know what
it's coming to happen you will let you
guys know but there's a lot of theory in
the book and there's a lot of how I have
applied it to help grow my business and
so it's the way I think businesses
should run that will help you get to
where you go
and make it more clear and then how I've
applied it in my business to achieve
rapid success and I wanted to then also
include other success stories in the
book to show people at different sizes
so we have somebody who has used these
strategies to build a
fifty-thousand-dollar company and then
who says is it half a million a half a
million yen or is that is there in
between I'm trying to think that no I
don't think no I don't think so yeah
$50,000 business half a million dollar
business million-dollar business five
million dollar business and then
plunging doing the business will do the
same so I wanted to show that no matter
what state you're at in your business
these strategies will apply to you and
also help you get you know if you're a
if you're a fifty-thousand-dollar
business you want to get two million you
know the strategy is the million-dollar
company uses can now be helpful for you
so I wanted to be applicable to almost
anybody and just the thought of writing
all of that stuff freaked me out I was
happy to do the interviews and get the
information out from them and for each
interview it took us four to five hours
yeah most of them took a good four hours
yeah i just have thought have been
distilling all that information and
transcribing it and making each page
makes sense and taking what they said
and crunching it down fit on the page
and flows just made me feel crazy crazy
like I don't want the truth the hiss and
so that's why I brought jenab orcas jen
is a a writer she writes fantasy copy
and I'm not to write and luster right
and he's great at it and felt like this
would be an amazing collaboration to
help me continue to do what I love to do
help make the book get out there a lot
faster and also I think make it more
valuable helpful and interesting because
if I was forced to do it then I probably
wouldn't do as good a job yeah are like
I might cut it you know honestly I might
get to the point like I'm right in like
you know what I can't do
is or I would drastically cut it down so
that I'm not spending time on things
that I hate and then that's a disservice
to the readers and so it's a lower
quality product and so by collaborating
I find that that's really helped save my
sanity and will help me create a much
better product and I love collaborating
with people because I'd like they're so
like an energy becomes from that too
right there's a synergy energy that
comes from from working with other
people and getting their thoughts and
then it inspires you to have more
thoughts and same thing and I just I
love collaboration so I've enjoyed
spending a lot yeah I think it's on
troopers is easy to get lonely
especially if you working from home yeah
I did it first and it was like I wanted
to shoot myself and then I started
working out of people it made it so much
better yeah and you can go to coffee
shops and sup tuna to kind of get out of
house of those people around you but
you're still working by yourself yeah
and we can be really isolating ya know
it is and a lot of people can't take it
and give up and go back and get their
jobs so working with others ideally face
to face like this is great but again
this is the first time we've met even
though we yeah we've connected online
many many times to school so so you know
first get past that thought that you
have to do everything yourself that
nobody will care as much as you and that
nobody else is able to help you you have
to go out and build a team and then
think about what you're not great at
what you don't love doing but that needs
to get done and then see who you might
be able to collaborate with who loves
that stuff to help you finish the
project cool so guys are the questions
not there any questions today only a
couple ask questions so this is how it
works I look at that you've got the glow
on anyone who's gonna close I asked your
questions and then again
same amounts of questions and then the
next week I'm just answering the
questions that I don't ask questions and
then we have these cycles so we need
that clinic consistency so next time ask
you some questions I'll answer for you
so first off is sherry who's suggesting
that we go check out k smith business
graphics here in Seattle and want to
give Sheree a shadow because we're here
in Seattle we should have figured that
out first you could have collaborated
with us on this video tune but thank you
cheri for the love next up new future
builder great video Evan thank you bro
you're right about celebrating your wins
i'm wondering how do you feel about
people incorporating hashtags into a
book it's a strategy i've heard about
and i'm wondering your tape we didn't
wash them I think were using hashtags in
your book so I think I know your answers
with me yeah yeah it's just funny so I
I'm in the process of acquiring a new
company and I brought on a new basically
a CEO to run I'm still officially in
charge but a guy in charge of all the
operations and I'm busy doing all these
other projects and he was asking about
hashtag is because this business has its
own one word hashtag and I gotta
understand if we should use this at
everything that we're doing because
isn't this just a Twitter thing and the
idea was something behind a hashtag is
yes it can help you with social media
but it represents an idea represents
something bigger than just that word and
so the difference between believe
lowercase B and hashtag believe and so
the idea is that you know whatever your
one word is that flows through
everything that you're doing and so
anytime we want to represent a bigger
concept in the book or or anything
social media that I share or in writing
e-mails back and forth to each other
with my team or with my audience if I
want something to represent a bigger
idea then I'll use hashtags in it and so
I don't think it's just a book marketing
strategy at least for us I think people
might use it and I think it could help
for us it's just how we communicate we
use it and everything that we
communicate and the book is just another
way to communicate and so yes it's going
to be in the book number of different
places
and you'll see when it comes in yeah and
then last question Peter will you do a
Europe tour I would like to meet you
once i'm going to do it or I don't know
I'm a game I'm game let's do it yeah so
i get i get asked a lot of questions
around the promotion of it promotion of
the book you know is it gonna be an
audiobook version are you gonna do tours
are you doing book signings are you
gonna do interviews my mindset right now
is just on finishing the book because
again we have to deliver it in january
to the pin january oh it's november we
are the freshest know I gotta hustle we
gotta listen and then it takes it takes
a year before it comes out have you and
what you got through that we gone
through this process no no it's my first
time so I don't know what's going to
happen in that process I'm assuming
after I deliver the book there's gonna
be a whole bunch of edits and revisions
and we'll go back and forth we'll see
what gets cut and maybe that creates
bonus content for you guys and then also
planning the release in the marketing
the promotion so rock right now my focus
is just on writing it and getting it
done because if I have a year to plan
out you know for me that's an insane
amount of time I'm going to go back
crazy in a year and so will I do a
Europe tour probably you know I go to
Europe every now and then I'm going I'm
going in March I want to say for a
conference in Madrid which is about how
it's about how librarians can use social
media to stay relevant I thought was
pretty cool libraries yeah yeah so I'm
keynoting it's librarians and museums
because they feel like their stuff is
getting left behind
and they want to stay relevant they feel
like kids don't go to libraries anymore
I just I think there's a lot that they
could do that they're not doing anyway
so I do speaking gigs and I travel and
so it would be cool to be able to tie on
a book tour potential to that I don't
know where you are let me know where
you're at because you watching if you
want a book tour tell me where you are
and we'll see if we can make that happen
if you leave it in the comments below
and so probably I don't know exactly
when or where or how and there's a bunch
of other marketing things that we're
probably going to do too and again I
don't know the details and once I finish
our draft and it's out then I'll be able
to focus more on the execution of the
marketing strategy cool so that's it
thank you guys for watching I'd love to
know what you think in the comments
below let me know what you think about
collaboration if you have a question
about that that you I'm going to answer
next time and if you have a question
about my book or the book writing
process or you want to write a book
leave it below and I'll answer it next
week on this episode that's it thanks
for watching thanks for collaborating
yeah thank you Seattle baby